football hall of famer who's been there
and done that and knows so much from the
tip of his finger than most people know
in their body about
football joining me here on the rich
eisen show once again on the
mercedes-benz van phone line is chris
carter how are you chris
rich how you and your family doing we're
better we're good man we're good how are
you doing how's your family you're good
everybody fine my family's good but i'm
just going to tell you rich i've had a
rough two weeks man what's happened
what's happened in the last two weeks
chris i mean i thought covert batman
covet for the last two years but when
you look at it two weeks ago yeah
harbaugh gets his first win against ohio
state i knew you weren't going to bring
that up but i'm that kind of guy i would
just bring it up to just get it out
there okay
and then last week my vikings
they go and lose to the winless lions
so i'm truly man every flag that that i
pass is at half mass okay um can i tell
you about my last two weeks chris
[Laughter]
can i blow float on since you since you
haven't participated in a long time go
ahead no no it's okay
it's okay chris i'm i'm living in the
here and now um
you know i'm i'm i'm trying to be
present uh as a host as a father
um as a football fan you know i'm trying
it's about being present
you know certainly for those who who you
love and i have nothing but love and
affection for you
um so
we dropped 42 on ohio state um which
then countered by
hiring a new defensive coordinator
and then uh
uh having um uh uh
a quarterback who is one of the top
games they're gonna hire a new defensive
coordinator rich um
even if you'd beat michigan that was
gonna happen is that what you're saying
absolutely yeah if you if you watch what
was going on in columbus if you watched
that run defense mm-hmm the last
responsibility yeah right then and our
linebacker play uh that has to be some
of the worst linebacker play i've seen
in ohio state man maybe 40 years and
then and then for notre dame right to
lose their coach and i do love marcus
freeman who comes from your uh neck of
the woods i know you must know mark as
well
um and i had a great chat with him
yesterday but for notre dame to then be
uh
uh denied a seat at the college football
playoff table because michigan then went
on and won the big ten championship it's
just been great it's just really great
you know my food tastes better the air
is cleaner um i feel like i'm sitting up
straighter right guys do i feel like am
i going to oh for sure yeah sure
definitely yeah so
uh yeah well the weather's not better
because i'm in southern california and i
know what you're looking for
it has been raining it has been raining
it has been raining uh okay so
i i did come on the air and say the
vikings if if we had to make a uh you
know the annual video about their season
the annual seasonal video it would be
called what the hell you know like so
what what what is happening like to what
do you attribute this viking season so
far going into this big thursday night
chris what do you have for me well for
one when you look at the roster
over the last five or six years
like this is not the most talented team
that zimmers had um there with the
vikings
and
defensively
i mean they're not nearly
the type of defense that zimmer would
you know put his name on
kirk cousins has played amazing he has
the wide receivers
excuse me he has he absolutely has and
jefferson is one of the
you would make a list of top five guys
in the league you'd have to include him
you'd have to yeah and and i wasn't a
huge kirk cousins fan and i do realize
that there's only so many
real elite quarterbacks in this league
but when you get out of that group um
kirk cousins are going to be at the top
of that next group as far as guys
competent weekend and week out and their
ability to throw the football so
um also if you look at some of their
leaders and how they've attacked kovit
you knew that they were going to have a
hodgepodge of guys missing games i'm
very close to that organization and i
know a lot of their leaders and their
best players are not vaccinated
so it's just a matter of time before the
russian roulette where there is a bullet
in the chamber and you start losing a
lot of guys so
losing close games that's not get uh
zimmer's mantra so that's what it's been
since week number one when cynthia um
beats him late on a kick
do you think zimmer's coaching for his
gig right now
chris
i think the will family has done a good
job
but
what would you say that he's done to
ensure
that he should
continue with the program because he's
been there long enough to have his
program established
and when you look at what's going on in
green bay look what's going on in
chicago um we know detroit it's been
basically the same for a long time i
wouldn't be surprised if the vikings um
made a move
and oh
so and i know this is difficult to have
that conversation because you're you're
tight with the organization and i know
you don't want to be seen as
speaking for it
but just in terms of watching this team
and what they're missing what do you
think they are missing what is the
missing ingredient right here
chris
well we know what the injuries and
everything they just can't get to the
quarterback it's hard for them to turn
the ball over
um
galvin cook you know outside of
jefferson their best offensive player
his inability to stay on the field and
be healthy because they're a different
offense when he's in the lineup and
that's been offered on for the last
three years so those are some of the
components that
lead you to mediocrity in nfl well it
seems like he my colleague from the nfl
network tom palisaro says that uh it
looks like a trending for cook to play
tonight um are you concerned about his
viability to come back from what appears
to be a torn labrum within
10 days
chris i mean that labrum is serious we
got a lot of guys playing with torn and
they're trying to make it to the
off-season to get that surgery but if
you look at dalvin i mean he's battled
you know on and off the field all season
to try to stay healthy
and when you look at that injury when it
happened you thought it was far more
severe than what it is and he's going to
try to get back in there but but what
does that mean
i mean how many snaps legitimately and
is he the elite player
you know with the partially torn labrum
um compared to the player that we're
used to seeing
chris carter here on the rich eisen show
and so uh do you think that this is in
fact big ben's final year or my buddy
adam schafter
reporting that he's told a bunch of
people what we i think all assumed based
on the way that his contract was uh set
up for this year that this is his last
year do you do you see a quarterback
that is on his last year right now chris
any quarterback that has ben's age
and tenure in the league and i don't
care if you play with one franchise i
mean new england
let tom brady go
not after having a bad year
because they were just moving on
eli manning if you look at him at the
end of his career
even if ben had a three-year contract
his play has dictated
that he's going to be moving on
you can talk about the contract and
that's just you know that's just a
matter of having a conversation but his
overall play ben roethlisberger is not
in the top 25 quarterbacks that we have
in nfl
so why would he continue
like it's time to give that spot the nfl
is a young man's game
and at some point all of us that's the
one thing we all have in common
me and moss used to talk about he'd be
like hey man or what you think i said
bro one day there's gonna be a guy show
up sit in your locker bigger faster and
stronger than you
that's who you are
okay
so it happens to all of us man it's not
foreign joe montana what happened to him
steve young
his play has dictated that his tenure in
pittsburgh is over so you literally said
to demoss back in the day i know you're
that guy for me you're that guy for me
to sit in this locker i'm uh you know
you're putting up a hall of fame career
with your resume
and you say that to randy moss to his
face that's what you said
yeah that's the reality rich
i mean
the people that know me and the people
are my friends they know that chris will
tell you the truth yes
and that was my reality it it helped me
throughout my career i'm also like
what's your goal i'm trying to play
three or four more years
go to a few more pro bowls
catch 80 90 catch 10 touchdowns
yeah have you dragged some of that
coverage away from me yeah that's what i
plan on doing but the bigger stronger
faster is here 1998 that's what dennis
green when he when he announced that
pick
that's what that meant
right and then obviously brady's in a
whole different class i would imagine
because of
how well he's playing at the age that
he's playing right now and it really is
his choice that father time still hasn't
knocked on his door and even
even tom it's going to and in the and
you know i want to read you this quote
from a sports illustrated piece that was
put out as tom won the sports person of
the year award just this week and and
and get your two cents on this brady
talking about the challenging part of
playing football for him right now if
anything he said i think it's the
emotional aspect of football for me when
we lose it's depressing when we win it's
a relief
it's not like the joy the happiness it's
a relief because when we win sometimes
just winning isn't good enough for you
because you expect
perfection and when you expect
perfection and it's less than perfect
you feel there's a down part
to that what do you think when you hear
that from tom brady
well rich i've been very fortunate
to be around thomas whole career
and there's certain things
that elite
people
in any field and tom is the one in our
field that we can say
like i've been associated with the
league since the mid 80s
i don't know how tom is feeling
no player in history has won as much as
him
no player in history had a
turned around a franchise like he did
new england and then have
the best coach in football give up on
him
before i know father time knocked on the
door in new england but tom told him
it's the wrong address you have to come
check me out in tampa man because i'm
getting ready to go there so i do
understand the relief from the
expectations
but it's the preparation that typically
gets the older players it's how do i sit
in these meetings five or six hours a
day with these 20 year olds and they're
talking about things that are irrelevant
how do i stay focused
the games are easy
it's the other six days and harnessing
those emotions that it takes to build a
play at an elite level and do it
consistently for a long time and tom
brady you know he is the poster boy for
that
yeah and uh i to me when i saw that
quote i was saying that sounds like a
coach right like you've been around
coaches that were at the end of long
runs and
and bill parfield that sounds like him
his hall of fame speech right you know
like it
or
i i heard it from um jim mora once told
me vermeel told me and i hope vermeel
gets to be in that bust gallery with you
this year he deserves it
um that he told me that the the losses
and the just the the depression from the
losses lasted way longer than any of the
excitement over a win and then hear that
the winningest guy in the history of
winning and we assume that's why he
still does it because he can win and he
loves the competition and he loves being
around the guys and he just loves all of
it that the wins are a relief i thought
to myself wow okay maybe he really is at
the end because i i believe he can play
till 50 if he wants the question is the
challenge and
the challenge isn't the physical aspect
it's the mental
is what we're just hearing from that
that's what i took from um you know
there are challenges
the biggest challenge is mentally but
don't think that the physical part is
not football is a physical game right
and if you could see even um statbat had
tom running at the fastest speed he's
ever run at in the game
still every play his career is in
jeopardy so there's anxiety
like he's just not out there playing
checkers man
no there's an opportunity that he can
get hurt so the physical is always there
right
it's always there even though they tried
to legislate hidden out of it but no
every week
a guy is trying to make his career by
clocking tom brady
knocked tom brady out the game
every week for over 20 years
that's a lot of physical pressure
which lends to the mental pressure as
well i mean and again i i i'm fascinated
the way that this is playing out the
rest of the season with the bucks rogers
is pushing 40 he just turned 38 this
week and it's and it could be down to
those two guys and then there's kyler
murray running like a deer the way that
he is i've got stafford on later on who
do you think is at the top of this nfc
roost when it's all said and done
as we get set for the vikings hosting
the steelers tonight to kick off week
14. chris i know they haven't done it
but i'm going to give the arizona
cardinals a chance
because they present a number of
problems for you offensively
and it starts with that quarterback
they run a number of sets that you're
going to have linebackers
and you're going to have safeties or
nickelbacks matched up on guys
that
they have them in a specific role and
killingsbury's done a a great job there
so
i'm looking for arizona i think everyone
right now is like old tampa bay and tom
and old green bay if they get home field
advantage
but if arizona gets that number one seed
and what they can do to stress out tampa
bay's defense with their lack of depth
as far as secondary
and green bay what they can do with
green bay um
i'm going with the cardinals
with a slight edge over those other
teams how about that all right how's
your uh
wide out uh your wide receiver one your
wr1 pod treating you how's that going
for you everybody's doing good it's
doing good man it was doing good you
talked to a lot of guys of course you
know why receivers are easy to chat it
up of course
the first year doing it was very very
rewarding outstanding outstanding so you
said you're here in southern california
that means you're here all month right
chris
no no i'm just i'm just dropping in like
i come in every two or three weeks
okay that's perfect so if it's two or
three weeks that means you're back here
for the rose bowl right that's what
you're going to be here for the rose
bowl you're coming here i'm back here
around i actually i'm probably going to
go watch michigan on
new year's eve oh in miami oh you know
that's where i reside
yeah but ohio state's coming here it's a
big game big game against utah huge
i mean you're not going to be here to
watch ohio state try to
knock off utah
chris
no hey rich yeah
huh hey rich stop it
stop
okay i said i'm going to the right
okay
well i mean that's where that's the
michigan guy that's because miami that's
cause the winner goes on to you know
play for it all i mean this is huge
stakes in that game
but out here there's a big
buckeyes utes game that needs you to be
here for it chris
right let me tell you something
you better be concerned about that front
seven of georgia boy
got some grown men
i'm sorry i can't hear you over the
checks that i'm writing right now
i'm so glad that you're back in the
rivalry
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh you saw that you you did see that leo
dicaprio raising the champagne glass at
you jiff uh that i tweeted at you right
you did see that oh of course okay nice
and
the um
uh booger
tried to send an all points bullets and
telling people to look for me but
i don't know someone like bruh somewhere
along the way booker thinks we're closer
than what we are
and and that's why i sent the clown face
now rich the classy
oh man absolutely okay absolutely okay
you you you cut me with a razor blade
dude try to hit me with the with the
machete
i can respect that rich
[Laughter]
great to see you chris and chat with you
you'd be well you take care a pleasure
you and your family right back at you
that's chris carter everybody he's gonna
be at the
national championship semifinal game
where michigan's at
and i'll be out here in los angeles
welcoming in all the buckeye faithful to
the big game against the utes
that ohio state is circling right now on
their calendar because that says that's
what it's all about
hashtag beat utah
for ohio state
i love that at the beginning chris was
like i know you won't bring this up and
i was thinking no no no no no no
no
i was just trying to be a professional i
understand of course like i'll bring it
no no question
do is bring
it all right hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here